[Music]
as our customers use cloud and bigger
ways it's becoming increasingly
important to simplify cloud management
deployment manager is an infrastructure
deployment service that automates the
creation and management of Google cloud
platform resources right flexible
template and configuration files and use
them to create deployments that have a
variety of cloud platform services such
as Google Cloud Storage Google compute
engine and Google Cloud sequel
configured to work together this
hands-on lab shows you how to use
deployment manager to create a simple
configuration file use that file to
create a deployment and then view
deployment information on a manifest so
what you'll do in this lab is create a
configuration deploy the configuration
inspect the running environment view the
deployment manifest deployment manager
allows you to easily deploy systems in a
variety of locations and provides the
control needed to easily roll out new
services it also gives you the
flexibility to deploy several versions
of your code simultaneously next up on
our quest is stack driver QuickStart
this self-paced lab is a part of the
deployment manager and baseline
infrastructure quests
[Music]